a alors beau personnage dans le film
vous êtes une opticienne way et le petit
garçon vous aime bien jusqu'à ce qu'ils
comprennent que vous vous êtes la
maîtresse de son père quoi sonia quand
on est miss france et métis ça va être
encore plus dur que pour les autres non
d'y arriver
bah ouais c'est des casseroles en plus
quoi ouais on est obligé d'être bonne
toujours on vous dit que vous avez parlé
avec mouss diouf avec dieudonné avec
légitimus qui vous en dis que ça sera
encore plus dur pour vous au départ oui
certains m'ont dit qu'il fallait que je
me batte deux fois plus que les autres
non moi je suis une fille très déterminé
et puis et puis j'aime réellement ce
métier donc voilà j'ai pas peur et puis
j'ai de très belles choses pour l'année
prochaine donc en vert à bon alors vous
avez pas pu aller assister à la
commémoration du génocide du rwanda
j'étais en tournage ouais ma mère a été
avec mon père mais bon écoutez je sais
pas quoi dire à propos de ça non mais je
passe tellement les choses
le président kagame vous le connaissez
vous l'avez rencontré quand il accuse la
france de ne pas avoir demandé pardon et
que ce pauvre nos muselier est obligé de
partir en courant vous pensez quoi
c'est peut-être vrai et peut-être aussi
que la france n'a pas fait les choses en
temps et en heure au moment où on avait
besoin justement d'entendre ça
tout le reste du monde d'ailleurs inde a
laissé cinq cent mille personnes se
faire tuer la machette sur bouger une
oreille
la belgique et l'onu se sont excusés la
france s'est pas excusé qu'il le fasse
il n'est jamais tard je pense que c'est
un respect pour pour toutes ces
personnes qui sont non seulement veuves
et orphelins
il ya 600 mille orphelins au rwanda et
serait bon de de leur montrer un certain
respect quoi ça vous embête de vivre
dans un pays qui s'est pas excusé pour
ce qui s'est passé oui ça m'embête mais
ce qui m'embête le plus c'est de voir
mon père en avoir honte quoi il est
français
je crois que les actuels c'est de la
merde ce qu'il faut faire c est d aider
les six cent mille orphelins rwandais en
tout cas il faut aller aider à les
donner de l'argent améliorer l'éducation
faire quelque chose construire des
écoles avec julio [ __ ] avec les
excuses des excuses
je veux que les choses s'améliorent que
les choses soient faites correctement ça
ne vous excusez pas fait quelque chose
sonia tout va bien pour vous on va vous
faire une interview ardilouze